It's time for our next game,
Birds Say the Darndest (BEEP).
Birds are second only to snakes
as the pet of choice for
lunatics.
Like bird (BEEP) on a newspaper,
YouTube is positively splattered
with pet parrot videos, so I'm
gonna list off two incredible
yet heartbreaking pet bird
talents, and for 250 points I
want you to guess which one is
real.
First one, does this bird sing
Everybody Dance Now or Bohemian
Rhapsody?
Marc.
>> Everybody Dance Now.
>> HARDWICK: Uh, let's find out.
>> ♪ Everybody dance now ♪
>> HARDWICK: So good, so good.
(vocalizing)
Oh, uh, can you guys time the
video-- (vocalizes)
>> ♪ Everybody dance now ♪
(vocalizing)
>> HARDWICK: He did...
That's amazing.
Uh, does this next parrot scream
into a cup or (BEEP) into a
bread
bowl?
Emily.
>> Scream into a cup.
>> HARDWICK: Let's see.
>> (screaming)
>> HARDWICK: Every day of my
(BEEP) life I feel like that.
>> Yeah.
>> HARDWICK: Uh, points.
>> That's the... that's the
truest thing you've ever said.
>> HARDWICK: It is, I think it
might be, I think it might be.
Uh, does this next bird say
"Don't touch me" or "No means
no"?
(bell dings)
Emily.
>> Uh, I'm just so sad thinking
about the home that this bird
lives in either way.
Like, there's not... there's not
a good way for this bird to have
learned either of these.
>> HARDWICK: Either way it's
not... this is a bad
environment.
>> So I'm gonna say-- I think
optimistically-- "Don't touch
me".
>> HARDWICK: Okay, let's...
let's hope, as the lesser of two
evils...
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> HARDWICK: ...that is the
case.
>> Don't touch me.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah.
Like... "Don't touch me" implies
"when I say this, you're gonna
stop."
>> HARDWICK: Right.
>> But "No means no" means
"we've al... I've already said
no."
I-I don't like thinking about
it.
>> HARDWICK: Don't think about
The parrot's fine, he's okay.
>> I think "No means no" is what
Leonardo DiCaprio says to the
bear.
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, I think so.
No, that's not... Matt, that was
already debunked by Vulture.
>> No, it's true.
>> HARDWICK: All right.
Next one, next one.
Does this parrot say "You got
it, dude" or "Peekaboo"?
Marc.
>> You got it, dude.
Come on.
>> HARDWICK: Let's see.
>> Peekaboo.
>> Peekaboo!
>> HARDWICK: All right.
I'm sorry. I know.
>> All those birds can say that.
>> HARDWICK: They're born with
it.